so i wanted to do a dna test just to
find out more about my ancestry
i was interested in the science behind
it all little did i know it was going to
completely
change my world
[Music]
hi i'm sam i'm 22.
last year for the holidays i decided to
get my family
dna test so i called my mom to tell her
that i was going to get them i asked if
she wanted one too
when sam said that she had decided to
get everyone dna kits
i immediately texted her father and said
we need to talk to them right away we
really never
thought there was going to be a need to
tell the kids because
there just didn't seem to be a good
reason for us to
even consider telling them again 25
years ago we started to
hear more and more about people who
find out really interesting things from
dna tests
so then we got we all four of us got
them for the holidays i expected to find
out
that we were probably from russia poland
hungary
and ireland but before we received the
results we had to have a big family
meeting and we did not know what that
was going to be about
her father and i had agreed that we
wanted to make sure we had an
opportunity to
tell them first before they found out
in a more surprising and disturbing
manner we always knew that this
information was going to be
extremely shocking for the kids we just
could not
find the right time to do it
and then we had to find the right time
to do it
in the year 2017 i didn't understand
what needed to be
in person and why we couldn't just skype
about it
we thought someone was dying we used to
say we would only tell the kids
if there was a medical emergency in
hindsight that would have been horrible
for someone to be stressed with a
medical emergency and then
you say oh by the way your dad's not
your dad
the day that we told the kids went as
well as
we could have expected after 21 years i
just learned that
my father was not my genetic biological
father
which just threw me for a loop just
based on how
similar we are i started just thinking
about nature versus nurture
when he and my mom were trying to have
kids they learned that he had a low
sperm count and they couldn't get
pregnant
my doctor said listen i'd recommend that
you go the donor route
you know what's important is that you
have a child so we went
and we got a bunch of faxes from the lab
we found a profile
because my ex-husband is 100 irish as
far as we know
it did say that the donor was german
irish and german was the first word used
when the kids told me that they were
going to do a dna test i was concerned
that they were going to see a lot of
german
genealogy and i thought oh my god how
are we going to explain that
i really thought that the results of
that dna test
would show to the kids that there was a
problem
yeah we just knew we looked more eastern
european jewish than
irish catholic and so that was never in
question
maybe my brother got his straight hair
or something from my dad but
never thought twice about it if we never
told the kids and then they
found out they would have thought i had
a long-term affair with someone
that wow we have the same biological
father but it's not
ours mom must have been doing something
but back to the story with my son
i think that i got pregnant on the
second try
and then the medical practice
they just said hey if you want we can
just save the leftover sperm
if you ever want it for any other you
know pregnancy and i said sure okay
and then when my son was about a year
old we said we would love to give
our son a sibling we have some leftover
sperm on ice
one that we thought we just want a
beautiful child we want a sibling
and it seemed to have worked well the
first time
immediately my brother and i were both
like okay like well you're still our dad
that doesn't change anything
i had a mentality that i was not gonna
not
figure out who it was at that brunch i
remember my daughter said
i want to find out who the donor is and
my son
said i don't want to know who the donor
is you can do whatever you want
i was not going to die without figuring
out who
the genetic father was when i was
awaiting my results i was
thinking what's the other genetic half
of me my mom said that she had the donor
profile
in the safety deposit box it was very
brief in his message for the parents it
just said
be a good parent said he was irish and
german
and said he liked to swim ski and play
tennis
i grew up playing tennis and swimming
and i ski and snowboard said that he
liked
travel i thought that sounded oddly
familiar i have a snow globe collection
for everywhere that i've traveled as
seen here there's over 120 of them
i did a tour through europe studied
abroad in australia been to
israel indonesia so well traveled
definitely after reading interest
looking at nature versus neurotrip and i
was kind of like
oh that's it like okay um
so the big uh distinguishing
characteristic on
his profile was the ages of his siblings
that was a huge
clue in my mind because he had
a lot of siblings that were around his
age he was probably 26 or 27 or
something at the time
and then he had this three-year-old
sister so this is all i had to work with
but i was gonna find him i knew i was
gonna find him fast forward about a few
weeks i finally got my
dna results from 23andme and
there was no genetic father match it was
just my mom and my brother who were on
there
i thought that maybe when we did the
first 23andme that he might have
have you know presented himself i
thought that it would be someone who may
or may not want to be
contacted by their biological children
does this person even want to
meet someone that was created through
a sperm donation because they needed
some money to pay for some classes
yeah but there was one second to third
cousin
and so i started to message her you know
i was looking for this
family of five kids two older brothers
three younger sisters
she responded and she started to send me
some family trees and i just started
scrolling through
these massive family trees and it was
just a massive
catholic family where everyone had like
10 kids
so these were like 200 page documents
looking for this set of five siblings
there was no luck there
so i also contacted the sperm bank they
couldn't reveal his identity obviously
but
they could tell me that they're a total
of eight pregnancies
from this donor i have potentially
six or more half siblings genetic half
siblings
i'm hoping to you know eventually
find as many of them as i can i kind of
hit this dead end
and then i knew that ancestor dna had a
bigger
database of dna relatives so i ordered
the ancestry dna test
got the results and once again no match
for the
genetic father so then i kind of just
dropped it for a while i was about to go
graduate from college and then start my
first real job and it kind of got put on
the back burner
but then a new second cousin popped up
and she said that she would ask her
family if they knew anything
in reality she did know who it was but
she wanted to check
first she then messages her mom
the donor's uh sister so the sister then
calls
her brother the donor and he picks up
the phone in the operating room at the
time
she tells him that there's this genetic
offspring or this genetic kid trying to
find him
he was like okay cool yeah give her my
number
so fast forward to the beginning of july
i just moved to florida for my first job
and i'm sitting on my mattress
on the floor because my bed has not
arrived yet
and i'm scrolling through furniture but
then an email pops up from that second
cousin
i open up the email and i read it and it
has his name
his email his phone number and that he's
open to talking
so yeah so
the second cousin said that he
lived in new york city and he had he was
not married and he had no kids
so immediately i'm thinking my brother
and his fiancee live in new york city
oh my god my brother could be walking by
him
every day and have no idea i think the
first thing i did was google him
um just typed in his name because i'm
thinking okay now i have
the name i can figure out what he looks
like so i google him
dr brian mailing an orthopedic trauma
surgeon dr brian maling is a world
renowned orthopedic trauma surgeon and i
start reading about him and all of his
medical work founder and chief medical
officer of blue horizon international
and i'm going to tell you a little today
about our groundbreaking work in the
stem cell arena
turns out he's a very googlable person
[Music]
hi my name is brian mailing you might as
well be honest
from the get-go because sooner or later
technology is going to catch up with you
you